urbain ou végétales abstrait ou
figuratif les paysages de bertrand
flachau entrouvre la porte d'un
imaginaire et une volonté de réinventer
le monde en une image complexe et
inédite
diplômé de l'école nationale des arts
décoratifs l'artiste crée des oeuvres à
la frontière de deux expressions
plastiques celle de la photographie est
celle du dessin c'est beaucoup de liens
intimes
quand on connaît l'histoire d'un
bertrand flash on se rend compte que
tous ces lieux qui photographie sont des
lieux qui pour lui ont une mémoire qui
ont une histoire
il ya un côté effectivement abstrait
figuratif en même temps il ya un côté où
on peut s'évader on peut se laisser
porter par les lignes de l'artiste ou
alors on peut être très concret en
garderont seulement les paysagés et
finalement faire abstraction de les
dessins chacun y voit un peu ce qu'ils
font à l'aide d'une tablette graphique
bertrand flash au sublime ses
photographies numériques
il peut aussi retravaillé directement
ses photographies argentiques par le
dessin au crayon une façon d'associer un
instant réel figer un dessin qui peut se
prolonger à l'infini
c'est un artiste qui s'appuie sur des
photographies qu'il prend les mêmes
des photographies de paysages de forêts
de bois mais aussi des photographies de
paris et après ils retravaillent
entièrement sa photographie avec du
dessin mais travailler avec sa tablette
graphique et sa tablette numérique pour
pouvoir sublimer les dessins donc
effectivement on est dans une technique
qui est plutôt original et plutôt actuel
bertrand flachau expose ses
photographies plastiques à la mezzanine
de l'hôtel de ville de guyancourt
jusqu'au 7 mai prochain